à l'est de l'ukraine
la bataille du dombass se prépare dans
les alentours de marioupol les forces
russes progress pour leur faire face les
etats-unis ont accordé une nouvelle aide
militaire à l'ukraine après un entretien
entre john hayes donné volodymyr lnsq un
nouveau paquet de soutien la défense de
l'ukraine a été discutée et approuvée
pour 800 millions de dollars armes
munitions d'autres formes d'assistance
système d'artillerie véhicules blindés
de transport de troupes et lisse je suis
vraiment reconnaissant de ce soutien
détaillé par le pentagone l'aide
militaire américaine comprend notamment
300 drones 500 missiles antichars 200
véhicules blindés onze hélicoptères de
transport
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de la guerre que les américains
fournissent de l'artillerie à l'ukraine
les états unis avaient jusqu'ici refusé
de livrer des équipements lourds de peur
d'être considérés comme partie prenante
au conflit mais le pentagone précise que
la bataille du donbass sera différente
de celle de kiev car cette fois les
forces russes se retrouve concentré dans
une zone de combat
ce nouveau plan des devises à répondre
aux besoins et craignez urgent pour le
combat des prochains jours alors que les
forces russes se concentrent désormais à
l'est dans leur agression impitoyable de
l'ukraine les etats unis ont maintenant
engager plus de 3 milliards 200 millions
de dollars dead à la sécurité de
l'ukraine depuis le début de
l'administration bytes
les etats unis sont plus que jamais les
plus gros contributeurs pour l'aide
militaire
washington fournit également beaucoup de
renseignements aux autorités
ukrainiennes sur les mouvements des
troupes russes afin qu'elles puissent se
préparer à cette nouvelle phase d'
attaque dans le donbass